hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in neutropenia ethics book 7 Aristotle
analyzes a very important moral
phenomenon called Achrafieh in Greek
which we can translate as lag or a loss
of self-control is also translated as
lack of self-restraint unrestrained
incontinence a whole bunch of ugly
things and the general idea behind it is
that a person knows what the right thing
to do is maybe even feels that it's the
right thing but then they do something
else instead
and Aristotle is interested in analyzing
this with respect to the the whole range
of objects that we might talk about
somebody being less than self controlled
with respect to now he talks about
unrestrained or lack of self-control in
a very general unqualified sense and
then he goes on to talk about it as it
applies to other types of objects and
that's what we're primarily interested
in here qualified or as he says cotton
man arose according to the part or after
the part forms of a cross
self-control the primary sense of the
term he says he is concerned with the
same sorts of things that temperance
itself of the virtue and in temperance
or self-indulgence the vice is concerned
with that is pleasures and not all
pleasures all together but pleasures
primarily of the body so Aristotle he
has in mind those of drinking you know
which would include not just you know
drinking alcohol but also you know water
and and other things milk perhaps eating
eating all sorts of things and then the
pleasures having to do with sex
we might extend it further than
Aristotle does in terms of other types
of physical comfort but I think that
that probably fits better under what
Aristotle is going to discuss a little
bit later in terms of softness and
endurance what you have to do lust with
pleasure and more respect with avoidance
of pain here we're interested in in
pleasure or desire for pleasure at the
thumb eeeh you agree and Aristotle says
look that's what when we talk about
somebody being unrestrained or lacking
self-control in the general sense that's
what we're talking about somebody who
who gives in you know example would be
somebody who eats too much candy they go
to the Christmas party or the holiday
party and there's bowls of candy all
around and they tell themselves well I'm
not on a diet but I also know that it's
not good for me to eat you know two
pounds of chocolate at a time but they
find themselves stuffing themselves over
the course of the evening and at the end
they look at the bowls and like wow I
should I sure eat a lot of candy we
could come up with all sorts of other
examples like that so we want to put
those aside how does aerosol going to do
that he's going to make a distinction in
these pleasures between those which he
calls necessary and those which are not
necessary whose objects in a certain way
are desirable for their own sake they
they don't make us
one of them because we need to satisfy
some physical urge but rather because
there's something about them that we
find attractive on their own account and
most of the things that he's going to
talk about as examples it's clear what
about the attraction the ends with anger
it's a little bit less clear but we'll
make that clear as we can a lot so he
does have a few things to say about
these these types of pleasures he says
the necessary sources of pleasures are
those connected at the bottom those of
nutrition and sex in fact those bodily
functions we've indicated as the sphere
of prolific a/c and temperance the other
source is a pleasure are not necessary
now he says those who go against the
right principle within them exceed in
regard to the latter class of pleasant
things we don't call unrestrained simply
hot blows we call them unrestrained with
some sort of qualification so we say
that guy can't you know keep it together
with respect to children and parents
that that woman over there can't keep it
together with respect to her driver for
victory or success and we can go on and
on with examples like this so he says we
give them a qualification we say
unrestrained as to money gain their
honor or anger not merely unrestrained
because we regard them as distinct from
the unrestrained in the strict sense
it's a very important point
how does this work them so he calls us a
crossing and the qualified sense as we
said kata marrows and it concerns these
these things that are not necessary for
us but we do in fact desire in somewhere
so the examples that he uses are the
ones that I've put here but we could
think of many other things probably
within our own society that could also
fit in with us for example if we don't
want to follow Aristotle in thinking
that visual spectacles and something
Gaming would be something that would
fall under temperance I think there's an
argument that can be made there but if
we don't do that then we could say
perhaps a person could be unrestrained
have a cross yeah with respect to video
games what would that look like they say
that they're only going to spend 20
minutes doing it and suddenly two hours
have passed and they've had multiple
points where they looked up at the clock
and they said oh I wasn't supposed to go
this far but their desire Spurs them to
go on against what it is that that right
principle or reason tells them they
ought to do so they give it and we could
think of many many other ways in which
this place now and these types of goods
we can also say well there's a lot of
things that fall under their scope so
let's look at the examples that he uses
very quickly victory or a success nikka
in in Greek the word we get Nike from
your shoes if you are the kind of person
who normally is pretty well put together
but you easily become a bit too
competitive in certain situations you
might be unrestrained with respect to
victory and if we think about the
broader term you know we talk about
people being winners or losers and some
people being obsessed with winning or
having you know sometimes a little
skewed notions of winning so they can
always be winning right that would be
what he's talking about here honor or
social status there's a lot of things
that people will do when they they you
know think that well this isn't quite
the right thing to do and I probably
should resist this desire but I'm going
to give in to it because it's going to
make me you know famous or get me on the
internet or
you know famous famous and internet
famous although the the difference
between those of those of roading as we
speak there is there's plenty of other
things as well people will often make
bad decisions on the basis of joining
some sort of what seems to be an
exclusive club there's a lot of
marketing scams that actually work this
way and that could be an example of
Achrafieh with respect to on our team a
wealth or game there's lots of cases
where people cut corners knowing that
they're cutting corners in order to make
a buck
Arizona uses the term wealth crema which
is you know property or money a game
care dos you know that's a little type
of victory or success trying to get
ahead you might say so all these sorts
of things can lead us to make decisions
that are in retrospect not good
decisions we don't follow what we know
to be the right thing we do know it to
be the right thing but we do otherwise
and all of these are examples of things
that are pleasurable for us but they're
not necessary pleasures we're not going
to diet we don't have them or feel like
we're gonna die unless we're really to
be able to go off with respect to them
in which case the person might actually
be the vicious and not just lacking self
control children and adherence I'll come
back to anger in just a minute children
and parents this is an interesting one
in turn Istanbul says that children and
parents are a good for us that we want
to do things for them we want to take
them into consideration that's what a
good person does however is possible and
you see many cases like this to go too
far and we might think of that going too
far in terms not just of excessiveness
that way like you know being so so
cautious about your children that you
force them to wear all sorts of clothing
that that isn't really what's with what
the weather is calling for or there's
maybe something similar like that with
age and parents but we can also think
about this in terms
leading us to ignore other important
goods that are at stake in the situation
that we a morally serious person would
take into account and people will often
say things like yeah I know that it's
not exactly the right thing to do but it
is my kid so I'm going to do this in
this case that would be an example of a
lack of self-control with respect to
children now any here is an interesting
case and we're we've got another video
specifically on Aristotle's remarks
about Achrafieh with respect to anger
anger is not a pleasant thing when you
feel that Aristotle says you're feeling
it because of a sense of pain of some
sort of insult or injury or you know
threat something that's been inflicted
on you or those who you are
conservatives or even things that you
you care about like for example
philosophies as it's also painful to
feel the emotion of anger what it is
it's pleasurable in anger is what
Aristotle calls Tim or ASIS which is
retribution we're setting things right
you know sometimes just getting people
to acknowledge hey I did the wrong thing
and you know you you're actually right
and I'm sorry for that could be Tim or
racist or it could be burning somebody's
house down or throwing them off a cliff
there's a lot of things in between all
right then so that's a little different
subject matter but in imagining or
hoping for Tim erases and then in
actually achieving Tim erases there is
pleasure and people can be excessive and
go against what they know to be the
right thing in situations they can last
self-control with respect to anger by
pursuing Tim or Asus they they lose
perspective we will often say so every
one of these is a form of qualified
across yeah like I said there could be
many more than Aristotle himself didn't
come up with but those
be up to you to think through